So, if we set things up this way, we actually
get some wonderful properties coming out. So here are some
things we know about this set up for zero-sum stochastic
games. Value iteration works, so we can actually solve this
system of equations by using the value iteration trick, which
is to say, we initialize these Q values to whatever
and then we just iterate this as an assignment, right,
we just say, you know, equals. So value iteration works.
This minimax Q algorithm converges under the same kinds
of conditions that Q learning converges, so we get this
nice, you know, Q learning analogue in this multi-agent
setting. The Q star that's defined by these equations is
unique, so we iterate it and we find it
and it's just, there's just that one answer. The policies
for the two players can be computed independently, that
is to say, if two different players are running minimax
Q on their own and not really coordinating with each other except for by
playing the game, that the policies that
they get out will actually converge to minimax
optimal policies. So it really does solve the zero sum game, which is maybe not
so surprising because, you know, they are
trying to kill each other after all. [LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
>> So, the idea that they'd have to
collaborate to do that efficiently would be weird.
>> [LAUGH] I never thought about it
like that, but, yeah, that would be weird.
>> The, this update that
I've written here can be computed efficiently, which is to say
in polynomial time. Because this minimax
can be computed using linear programming.
>> Yes of course.
>> And, finally, if we actually iterate this Q
equation and, and it's converging to Q star, knowing Q
star is enough to figure out how to behave optimally.
So we can convert these Q values into an actual
behavior, again, by using the, the solution in the linear program.
>> So it's just like MDPs of value iteration with Q-learning?
>> Exactly. It's like we've gone to, to
a second agent and it really hasn't impacted things
negatively at all. This is, this is all
the, pretty much all the things that we want,
come out. There, there are some things that
don't come out. For example, in the case of
an MDP, we can solve these, this system
of linear equations in polynomial time. Not just by
value iteration, but we can actually set up it as a single linear
program and solve it and be done in linear time or, sorry, not linear
time, polynomial time. This is not known to be true in the zero-sum
stochastic game case, it's not known whether
it can be solved in polynomial time.
>> Hm.
>> So there, it is a little harder as a problem, but it's, you know, not
harder, not deeply harder and not harder in
a way that matters in a machine learning setting.
>> Cool.
>> So this is really great. So let's,
let's try to take this same approach and
see if we can deal with general sum games.
>> Okay.